de la amenaza nuclear a la biológica los
escenarios apocalípticos aparecen ante
la invasión a ucrania rusia pidió este
miércoles explicaciones a eeuu sobre la
supuesta destrucción de un programa
biológico militar en ucrania que
contenía enfermedades mortales como la
peste cólera y ántrax
estamos confirmando los hechos que se
dieron a conocer de que durante la
operación militar especial en ucrania
hubo una limpieza de emergencia de los
programas biológicos militares por parte
de kiev y financiados por eeuu whisky
financiero año seguido nuestra familia
estas especulaciones surgieron después
de que marco rubio senador republicano
estadounidense preguntase por la
existencia de material biológico en
suelo ucraniano la subsecretaria para
asuntos políticos del departamento de
estado victoria nuland dijo lo siguiente
estamos ahora bastante preocupados de
que las fuerzas rusas puedan estar
buscando hacerse con su control
después de este suceso y antes que rusia
china ya había reaccionado a la posible
existencia de estos laboratorios y estos
laboratorios biológicos almacenan en
cantidad de virus peligrosos las
actividades de militarización biológica
de eeuu en ucrania son sólo la punta del
iceberg bajo el manto de reducir el
riesgo de bioseguridad a través de la
cooperación y fortalecer la salud
pública mundial el departamento de
defensa de eeuu ha tomado el control de
336 laboratorios biológicos en 30 países
del mundo
sin embargo el uso militar de estos
laboratorios biológicos ha sido
calificado por el pentágono de absurdo
mientras que un portavoz presidencial
ucraniano negó la acusación